-Welcome to the show.
You look sharp.
You look great, bud.
-Thanks, bud.
I have a great stylist.
Warren Alfie Baker.
Shout-out to Warren.
-Yeah, nice job.
-Yeah.
-I want to go through a couple
things I think that we have
in common.
-Yeah.
-First of all, I heard that
we both drive trucks.
-Yeah. You have a truck?
I have a pickup truck,
a Ford F-150.
-Ford F-150.
-[ Laughs ]
I have a Raptor.
Do you have a Raptor?
-No. I love the Raptor.
-Raptors are pretty cool, man.
They're like a super truck.
I didn't need it.
I bought it when I was in L.A.
'cause I had a business
and we sold merch,
and I had to move merch around.
But like a regular F-150,
I was like, I could get that,
or I could spend twice as much
and have a truck that was ready
for the zombie apocalypse
and I was like
I'm going to go with that.
-They're cool-looking.
You go, oh, wow. No, I got mine.
I got a Ford F-150. I'm getting
the new one, the electric.
-Oh! Oh, the electric one?
The Lightning?
I want to get that one.
-I went to the factory
and watched them build it
and everything in Detroit.
-Stop.
-Oh, yeah.
-Can you tell them I'd like one?
Can I get the Jimmy --
[ Laughter ]
-Get the Jimmy Fallon
skip the line, yeah.
-Thank you.
-I got mine to a --
'Cause every Halloween, I get
a couple of pumpkins
and I need to put
them in something.
[ Laughter ]
So, I got a truck.
I put a couple pumpkins
in the back.
-You got to go on
those pumpkin runs, man.
-Pumpkin run, man.
It happens once a year,
but you've got to make sure.
-Pumpkin runs for the people.
Not gonna put them in the back
of a car.
They need to be in the back
of a truck.
I love my truck.
-Yeah.
-But you haul things too?
Like, real stuff?
-I mean, every once --
I'm really honestly,
like, I love it.
It's great.
I live on a ranch.
I moved up to Austin,
and I have a bunch of
land up there,
so it's very helpful for that.
But moving out, I hauled, like,
a U-Haul out there.
And then I went
and got an Airstream.
My first house out
there was an Airstream.
-What? Now, that's next level.
-Yeah.
-I have the attachment.
-Stop it!
-I can hook things to my truck.
-But I have not --
That's as far as I've taken it.
-Well, listen. I'm not --
-"I could something with this."
-I'm not very good
at towing things.
I'm surprised I didn't get
pulled over multiple times.
But I was able to pull my
Airstream to my property.
And I lived in my little silver
potato for a while.
It was great.
-Wow!
What's it like living in
an Airstream?
-Honestly, I love it
'cause I love
little tiny homes and things.
I'm just not a very tiny person.
-You're big.
How tall are you?
-6'4", 6'5"-ish.
-Yeah.
-Depending on if I'm slouching.
-Whoo!
-I like the "whoo."
-Yeah.
-Was that for 6'4" or for 6'5"?
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Boo, 6'4."
6'5"? Ow!
[ Laughter ]
-I have these, like --
I loved living in it.
Honestly, I could have done
a lot longer.
But the shower in it -- my -- I
have abnormally wide shoulders.
And so, I would be facing
the shower.
And I'd be, like, washing
the front of me.
But you have to stay really
tidy, and then I would just try
to turn around and my shoulders
would pop the door open.
And then all the shower water
would be pouring out.
I'm like, "This is not --"
-It doesn't work for you.
-"This is not tenable.
I can't do this anymore."
-Another one of the things I
heard that we have in common is
we both did impressions
when we were kids.
-Oh, yeah.
-You did?
-Well, yeah.
I mean, don't we all?
I guess. I don't know.
-I don't know.
I don't think everyone does.
-Well, I guess. I don't know.
I grew up watching
so many cartoons.
I mean, I think I learned how to
act from Bugs Bunny, honestly.
Like, you know, I mean, just all
the voices and all the things,
all the Saturday morning
cartoons and all that.
-You did all those?
-Yeah, I mean, you know.
But then everybody --
Well, I guess not everybody,
but some people,
yuk-yuks like us,
we like to do, you know,
impressions like Walken,
but everybody's got a Walken.
-Christopher Walken is always
good to have.
-Yeah, Christopher Walken,
[as Walken] you know.
[ Normal voice ]
But what I always thought --
I wonder if Walken
has a Schwarzenegger
and I wonder if Schwarzenegger
has a Walken.
You know what I mean?
-So, like, if they do
impressions?
-[ as Walken ]
Get to the chopper, come on.
[ Normal voice ]
You know, like that.
[ Laughter ]
Like, come on.
-"Come on, get in --
get to the chopper."
-"Come with me."
-"You're telling me
get to the chopper?"
-[ as Walken ] Come with me if
you want to live, Jimmy.
You know.
[ Laughter ]
Or, like Schwarzenegger, like --
you know, it's always, like,
those famous, like, Walken
monologues, you know, so...
[ as Schwarzenegger ]
It's like, "I had this watch,
it was your father's watch.
I hid it in my ass
for five years."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I've never seen Schwarzenegger
do Christopher Walken.
-[ Normal voice ] I know. I'm
like, "They got to have one."
-That's fantastic. I love that.
Can we talk about
"Shazam! Fury of the Gods"?
-Yes, I would love to.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congrats. Congrats on this.
-I would love to.
-Giant, giant, giant movie.
-Yeah.
-Big movie.
You got to be psyched about
this.
The first one crushed.
I read somewhere that you
auditioned for Shazam
or for a different role.
-Yeah, so, the long
and the short of it --
I'll try to keep it short --
but basically --
-No, dude. Make it long.
We won't care.
-Let me take all the time.
-We love you.
-Thank you, man.
I appreciate that.
So, look, a couple months before
I got the job, I was offered
an audition for
the role of Shazam,
but I knew enough about
the character of
Shazam Captain Marvel that he
had, like, an evil twin named
Black Adam, and Black Adam was
being played by The Rock.
And I was like, "Well, wait.
So they're supposed to be twins?
Like, there's no way
I'm getting this job."
-"Just so you know, I'm not
getting this one."
-Yeah, totally.
And also, unbeknownst to me,
I was in kind of a dark place
in my life at that point.
And then fast-forward about
a month and a half later,
and I'm in this super-intensive,
life-saving therapy
and I learned how to love
myself, really,
for the first time in my life,
and I have this whole
breakthrough, and then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
By the way, go love yourself.
If you learn nothing else today,
go love yourself,
go love yourself. Okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, even though I tell my agents
I was like,
"Hey, I'm going to be off grid
for a little while."
They're like, "Yeah, yeah.
Totally."
Two and a half weeks in,
they're like, "So, listen."
There's an audition, it's
for a whole other role.
It's a supporting role.
If you want to do it, cool.
If not, that's fine too.
We understand you're doing
some healing."
I was like, "Cool."
I just had this breakthrough.
I'm like, "I'll go, whatever.
I feel good about myself.
I'll go and do --"
I did one take. I sent it in.
And then in the course of,
basically one week, I ended up
going from auditioning for this
whole other role to them saying,
"Hey, we think
you're our Shazam."
They flew me to L.A.
I had done all my therapy
that I needed to do.
I go to L.A. I audition.
And within one week,
I was Shazam.
And it was all --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it was super crazy, man.
-Good for you, bud.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That is so good.
What a great story.
-Yeah, I just think it's
indicative of, you guys,
when we do the real work, when
we do the work to heal ourselves
and help other people heal
themselves,
and that's where all
the good stuff comes from.
You know? And that's where that
blessing landed in my life.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so happy.
What going on in this "Shazam"?
What can we tell people?
-So much. So, in the first
movie, Billy Batson,
the kid that I am the super
version of, he was 14.
Now he's 17, almost 18, so he's
about to age out of
the foster-care system, so he's
kind of freaking out about that
'cause he doesn't want to lose
this family he just found.
And then he's feeling a little
imposter syndrome like we all do
'cause he's supposed to be
the very competent leader of
his super family but he's really
blowing it a lot of the time.
And then there's these three
goddesses played by
Dame Helen Mirren, Lucy Liu,
and Rachel Zegler,
who come to --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They are honestly --
-They are so great.
So great. And they come to kill
me and my family.
So, there's a lot going on.
-Yeah.
A lot of action, a lot of comedy
as well, by the way.
-Yeah, lots of fun.
-You do a really great job.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Zachary Levi
in "Shazam! Fury of the Gods."
Take a look at this.
-Okay, look. I might not have as
much experience as you
'cause I'm not, like, super old
like you.
But I think I have a few
experiences that you don't have
'cause I've seen all the "Fast &
the Furious" movies, lady.
And let me tell you something.
It's all about family!
[ Dramatic music swells ]
[ Music stops ]
Family!
Guys, that was the signal.
We practiced this like 12 times.
Thank you.
Forgot all about my family,
didn't you, goddess?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"It's all about family!"
Zachary Levi!
"Shazam! Fury of the Gods" is in
theaters and IMAX this Friday.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around. Go see it!
-Go see it, go see it!